all right guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money
right we're gonna do something new today
on this beautiful beautiful monday
morning clint and i are gonna play a
little game i'm gonna throw out the name
of a company we're gonna talk about the
company very quickly
we're gonna do this for about 10 minutes
and then we're both going to give you
our opinion and we'll move on to the
next company first
is the sponsor of lunch money block five
they allow you to do three things you
can buy and sell crypto on a crypto
exchange
you can deposit crypto earn up to eight
point six percent apy an interest
bearing account
or you can take out a usd loan and get
your crypto collateral what do you think
about block five i like zack okay
zach is the ceo all right so i think
it's interesting what they're doing
because you can
basically earn interest yes on
your bitcoin while it's just sitting
there right yes
so i think it's interesting why not earn
eight percent
apy on your interest bearing account
so blockfy.com go check it out
blockfy.com
uh i'm obviously a massive massive fan
uh i think that they are building the
most innovative crypto
financial products right so whether it's
the interest bank account the exchange
the
uh us dollar loans guess crypto
collaboration with the credit card
credit card etc so i think it's really
really cool all right second one is a
one that i am not an investor in
clubhouse what do you think we should do
the pros and the cons okay what do you
think about clubs so
clubhouse i like i
for some reason i'm like hot and cold
with clubhouse like i go on there
if i see a like an interesting room
maybe i join but i don't stay too long
like i don't have the patience to sit on
there for like two hours like some
people
do um i think it's cool i think it's
like the new town
square what i think it's the new you
said hot and cold
and for older women isn't that oh my god
so it's that i don't even know what he's
doing it's like the town square
but i don't know and that has to do with
anything um
it's the new town so i was gonna say
times square
the new town square and people can talk
about whatever they want
of course now you know they're getting
into moderation issues
people are sounding the alarm on
conversations they don't like that are
taking place on there
but andreessen keeps pouring money into
it so we'll see what happens
drop in social audio i think is the way
people are describing it live podcast
andreessen did around around 100 million
evaluation then a billion
now 4 billion all that's happened the
last 12 months
i personally think that it's still
undervalued
uh i haven't used it a ton but i think
it's a great way to
very quickly get people all in one place
and get the authenticity of a
conversation
all of the moderation policies all that
kind of stuff uh to me is overblown
in the sense that what people are really
asking for is the censorship of free
speech
so again we get into this weird world of
are these platforms or are they
editorial services
right if all of a sudden you say the
difference between platform and
publisher
yes and i think that one of the
interesting things is that
uh i personally don't agree with some of
the content that's on there
but i also understand that uh in a
public place you have the right to have
free speech even if you say things i
disagree with
now clubhouse is not necessarily a
public place it's a private company
and so therefore clubhouse has the right
to serve or deny
service to anyone they see fit frankly
they don't need a reason right they can
simply say i don't want to do this and
so
it's a very complex issue but i do think
that uh
while that gets a lot of the headlines
because that's kind of the most
controversial thing
uh overall the service is great it
serves people's needs there's millions
of people using it
uh people built really big followings
and i really like their approach to
creator monetization
uh how they're gonna basically help the
people on the platform make more money
i think that's really not taking a cut
so how are they making money of some of
it
but i'm sure that in the future they may
uh introduce a way to take a cut or they
may introduce other things that they
take a cut of okay so
i think that this is uh this is
generally really good it's a step in the
right direction
all right next one i am an investor in
synthesis synthesis
what do you think about that one i
really like synthesis what is it
education is broken
synthesis is trying to educate
kids via um virtual
games how would you like video games
basically the traditional
education system teaches rote
memorization
simply to help them pass the
standardized test at the end of the year
but if you want to be successful in life
you probably don't need rope
memorization what you need is critical
thinking and problem solving skills and
so synthesis
was born out of uh a school that elon
musk created for his own kids
at astra and then uh now you can go you
can subscribe
uh on a monthly basis if you're a parent
and you have a kid between ages i think
it's like 7 and 14
and it's been growing very very quickly
uh and the whole idea is just they're
going to teach your kid things your kids
will never learn in school
around problem solving critical thinking
and right now it's an enrichment program
so it's not a replacement for school
but it's an enrichment program that you
can do additional to school
but i actually i was thinking about it
and i think it would have really
benefited kids like me where
i spent the majority of being in class
like bored it was worksheets it was all
this like multiple choice i was like
this literally is not helping me like
i wasn't critically thinking by any
stretch but
but what this does is it puts people
like me and you
let's say we were in middle school
together we were we would be very
different
students in the traditional school
system but if you put us together in an
enrichment program like that you would
see how the different ways that we think
and we might actually have been friends
i had to throw rocks at you on the
playground okay this is virtual
virtual rocks are even more harmful than
real rocks everybody knows
please i would have please uh if you
want to go check out synthesis where you
have young kids go sign up at
synthesis.is
uh let's talk about jack mahler's and
zap or strike what do you think about
him
i think jack is really good at chess
i to be honest i don't quite understand
what his company does but i know he's
good at chess so strike is basically a
p2p
payments provider is it an on-ramp
uh in some ways if you think about it
basically they can help you send any
currency
in the world to anyone else in the world
cheaper and faster than anybody else so
they can send one dollar
around the world faster than uh square
or venmo or paypal or your bank or
anybody
uh and they use the bitcoin rails as a
payment uh component
uh it's very very interesting he
actually just went he's been living in
el salvador for the last couple of
weeks and he launched the app in el
salvador
and it became the number one app in el
salvador
our number one finance app in el
salvador and i think he's like the top
20
apps overall in the country that's cool
uh but the reason why she says he's good
at chess is he a two-time high school
state champion in chess the only person
he can't beat
here is my dad no
i could beat your dad i could beat jack
malls i'm undefeated ain't nobody gonna
mess with me
those who miss evo and won an evo update
he texted me that he just won third
place
in a tournament of one minute i think
fisher chess where like all the pieces
are mixed up and you got one minute to
go
you got third place out of thousands of
people who knows how many there were no
there was thousands
by the time that we published this i'm
gonna be telling people there was
millions of people in the tournament um
hold on and uh there was one more oh
wait can can we talk about
one company i want to talk about sure
last one the profile
what do you think what are the pros and
the cons
be careful with the cons what is the
profile
do you know what the profile is no no
tell people the profile is a company
that i started
and we study interesting and successful
people via long form profiles
every sunday and wednesday if you pay
are you running an ad right now can you
can you tell us
tell what what do you think about this i
enjoy reading it it actually
is intelligent and i'm not just saying
that because she's here
when she's not around to actually say
nicer things than when she's here
because i can't let her head get too big
uh but basically every single week she
reads way too much content
finds the best pieces puts in an email
on sunday and then you get to go
and benefit from her saving you all this
time super high quality articles about
the world's most successful
uh people are companies and then uh the
cons
frankly if i really have to admit what
the cons are there's three of them
one oh my god i gotta be told about the
profile every day all day long and
whenever anybody signs up she gets a
notification on her watch
and then she's like oh new customer
which you know it gets annoying after
thousands of them uh the second thing
millions
the second thing is uh with profile
polina refuses to send it out on sunday
uh unless she has read it to me which
means that on saturday afternoon or
saturday night
she will read to me out loud the entire
profile
which means by the time i click on it on
sunday morning i've already consumed
you're so lucky it's like an audio
version that no one else gets
and then lastly the most annoying part
of the profile
the most annoying part is that there are
times plane doesn't even know
oh there are times surprise
there are times where i've worn that
t-shirt out in public and people say oh
do you work at the profile
and i say yes i'm an unpaid intern
readtheprofile.com thank you okay hold
on it's ask lunch money time hashtag
ask elem in the comments below we have a
moist update
day 98 of commenting the wait continues
in the meantime i'm stacking sats
getting swole moist come on and
finessing online school
you're procrastinating this email od
what does that mean
but that's just another thing you and i
have in common i promise i'm not a crazy
serial killer if that's what you're
concerned about
i don't know people who promise they're
not crazy serial killers
i promise i'm not one too all right
yeah moist you're giving me the you know
after this all right see you guys later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends